Here's F Michael, so
just like I wrote R is an expectation
over the set of rewards that
you're going to see after k steps.
I'm going to write F in the same way.
And I've sort of got some
really funky notation here but
let me try to explain it.
In English,
F is simply the [LAUGH] expectation of
me in ending up in s
prime after k steps.
So this Delta is because I can't
draw lowercase deltas well,
this is a delta function.
It is one in the case where
the kth state that I see
is actually equal to s prime,
and zero otherwise.
And Delta to the k is just, well the
discount factor raised to the kth power.
So, F is an expectation over after
I've executed the option that
I will end up in state s prime.
Having started in state s and
having taken k steps.
Now notice, why do I even
have to go through all this?
Why couldn't I just put T of s,o,
s prime here?
Well first off, T is defined in terms
of A is not defined in terms of o,
but that's okay.
The reason I have to do this
little funky thing, and
why we call it F instead of T,
is because.
As you pointed out in the beginning,
there needs to be a discount factor
attached to the value of the next state,
which, in this case, is s prime.
So what we've done is, we've rolled
up that discount factor inside of F.
So F is the expectation
of me starting in s,
taking option zero,
ending up in s prime after k steps.
And the Delta sub k gets sort of
brought along with that expectation so
that I can appropriately discount the s
prime state that I will end up in.
>> Hm, okay.
>> Right, so in the end, both R and
F are just expectations,
they're exactly doing what they
were doing in the original Bellman
equation that we were using before.
In the original Bellman equation
the reward was just the immediate reward
that we got for taking an action here.
The reward is just an expectation over
all the rewards that we're going to see,
given that we've taken
this particular option.
If the option is in
fact a single action,
then it would be exactly the same
thing as a reward we would get for
being in that state and
taking that action.
Similarly, F is just the transition
function, except now it's sort of
the accumulation of all
the transitions of starting in s and
ending up in s prime.
After k steps given that I took
the particular actions that are inside
of the option, and dividing by pi.
Now there's a couple of
neat facts about this and
I will write them down
on the next slide.
But I just want to point out what's
particularly cool about this,
is that it really is a Bellman equation.
It really does allow us to do all of
the things that the Bellman equation,
Bellman operator allowed
us to do in MDPs.
But it allows us to analyze or
to reason about or
to plan over this multiple
variable time MDP.
So, in fact,
this kind of MDP has a name,
which I probably should
have written down earlier.
And it's called SMDP, where the S
stands for, what do you think, Michael?
Something?
Yes, and that something is Semi, so
this is called
a Semi-Markov Decision Process.
And the difference between
the Markov Decision process and
the Semi-Markov Decision Process is,
you get to make these jumps in time.
And because we have this Bellman
operator that takes into account
all the possible jumps in
time that you might take.
In the end,
it grounds out to an underlying MDP and
allows us to inherit all the things
that Bellman allowed us to in here.